le défenseur des droits est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir jacques toubon au
soir inconscient et merci d'être avec
nous pour ce rendez-vous de public sénat
avec la fp avec perrine tarneaud et
deborah cloud alors que vous montrer
beaucoup de réactivité depuis votre
nomination l'été dernier peut-être pour
faire l'unanimité plus encore que
l'incompréhension s'en souvient c'est
l'hostilité un que vous avez dû
affronter après votre choix par le
président de la république par françois
hollande on en parlera tout à l'heure à
la fin de l'émission mais on va le voir
d'abord votre champ d'intervention est
immense alors au risque peut-être
d'ailleurs de nous faire douter que la
france est un état de droit justement
mais il ya tant de vigilance à
manifester pour sauver notre vivre
ensemble tant de causes à défendre et
nous allons évoquer d'abord celle des
enfants nés de mères porteuses
si vous êtes d'accord la pratique on le
rappelle est interdite en france mais la
justice se contredit et puis l'exécutif
semble sur le problème sur l'inscription
à l'état civil des enfants nés par gpa
vous défenseurs des droit qu'est ce que
vous réclamez pour eux nous nous
réclamons la mise en oeuvre d'un
principe fondamental
du droit fondamental qui est reconnu par
une convention internationale qui ça
comme qui s'appelle la convention
internationale des droits des enfants
qui remonte à 25 ans maintenant et qui
dit tout doit être fait pour servir
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant et en
l'occurrence dans cette affaire de
manière très simple l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant c'est que cet enfant qui n'a
rien demandé qui n'est responsable de
rien est une identité
ce qui veut dire d'un côté une
nationalité une citoyenneté et de
l'autre côté un état civil est la
question qui est en discussion
actuellement c'est que du fait que en
france la gestation pour autrui est
interdite et c'est très bien je suis de
caen partisans de l'interdiction parce
que en fait feu de paille éthique pour
vous c'est en fait là la mécanisation la
marche 10 à sion du corps humain et
c'est tout à fait contraire à nos
principes non mais du fait de cette
interdiction
le il y à un certain nombre de personnes
à la fois sur le plan politique et un
somme de juridiction qui considère qu'
on ne peut pas transcrire pour ses
enfants l'état civil qu'ils ont acquis à
l'étranger or pour la cour la courbe pas
moi peuvent la cour européenne la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a dit
le 14 juin dernier au nom de l'intérêt
de l'enfant il faut transférer tassili
c'est à dire de manière très concrète il
faut inscrire ses enfants sur le livret
de famille de leurs parents pour leur
donner une filiation alors et je suis
pour des raisons juridiques essentiel
favorable à cette position et j'ai dit
au gouvernement j'ai dit à madame
taubira puisque c'est elle qui est en
charge de la relance et régulière gelé
je lui ai dit je lui ai dit que il me
paraît nécessaire que la france le
gouvernement et la france se mette en
conformité avec cette décision de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme il
est d'accord avec vous sur le fond la
garde des sceaux puisque l énergie même
lors des questions au gouvernement à
l'assemblée nationale elle a expliqué
que les enfants nés sous djibrilla
étaient les enfants de la république une
digue beau mais cette réponse et une
réponse un peu incantatoire parce qu'en
réalité la garde des sceaux a une double
position sur la nationalité elle a fait
il y a maintenant deux ans une
circulaire en disant il faut délivrer un
certificat de nationalité c'est à dire
un passeport et on a vu qu'il y à des
juridictions qui le font d'autres qui le
font pas la cour de cassation va être
appelée à trancher bien récemment il ya
eu par exemple une décision d'un
tribunal de paris qui a infirmé le refus
par le préfet de police de délivrer des
passeports sur ce sujet là christiane
taubira est tout à fait dans le sens je
dirais que moi mais mes en revanche sur
l'état civil non parce que sur l'état
civil sur l'état civil jusqu'à
maintenant elle n'a donné aucune
instruction au parquet de nantes qui est
en charge de l'état civil des personnes
nées à l'étranger
elle n'a donné aucune instruction pour
que soient transcrits les actes mauvaise
vie et c'est là que le parquet a fait
appel voilà et c'est pour cela que sur
ce jeu oui mais je pense que le parquet
a fait appel sans avoir besoin
d'instructions à supérieur à mon avis et
est donc le aujourd'hui sur ce sujet là
il y a effectivement en l'absence de
position de gouvernement il y a des
décisions contradictoires
il va falloir letrange est allé c'est
clair que la garde des sceaux ne peut
pas dire je suis complètement dans ce
sens de la décision de la cour
européenne parce qu'en réalité ce qu'a
demandé la cour européenne le
gouvernement actuel de la paf et donc
est incantatoire saddam tombe bien on
parle des enfants de la république
qu'avec l'ipad et en fabrique ses lyrics
et moi aussi je suis là en tant que
défenseur des droits pour faire en sorte
que la république tienne ses promesses à
l'égard de tous sur notre territoire
mais je pense qu'il faut aller au delà
et encore une fois la chose est
extrêmement pratique est ce que on
inscrit ses enfants sur le livret de
famille des personnes qui sont leurs
parents on l'apprend c'est ce que
demande de la cour de cassation
l'inscription à 6 si la cour de
cassation prend cette position je m'en
félicite la cour de cassation jusqu'à
maintenant je dois le dire depuis
quelques années a toujours pris dans ses
plus hautes instances et notamment la
saône assemblée plénière a toujours pris
des positions qui s'oriente vers la
reconnaissance
de toutes les modes de reproduction et
vers la reconnaissance aussi de toutes
les formes de sexualités coeur et en
particulier d'année dernière la
contestation a donné un avis pour
reconnaître le droit d'adoption aux
femmes qui venaient en couple et je
crois que cette affaire est très simple
c'est une question d'égalité moi dans
mon boulot
j'essaye de faire en sorte que tout le
monde quels que soient ses préférences
quelle que soit sa condition soit traité
également c'est vrai pour les régions
groupe colabor je trouve que la cour de
cassation je trouve que la cohabitation
des cela étant alors il ne me regardait
donc pour répondre est ce que la gpa que
la gpa reste interdite et ça je pense
que ça exigerait de la part de notre
gouvernement une action comme on l'a
fait à d'autres époques il ya quinze ans
que cette interdiction internationale à
l'action internationale comme on l'a
fait il ya dix ou quinze ans
pour interdire le clonage humain
reproductive c'est à dire de faire des
personnes identique à partir de cellules
on pourrait très bien se battre pour
avoir une convention internationale qui
interdisent la gestation pour autrui et
en particulier la gestation pour autrui
dans des conditions commerciales c'est à
dire les maires qui sont obligés de se
vendre pour faire des enfants pour nous
est alors pour être précis donc le
procureur général près la cour de
cassation va recommander l'inscription à
l'état civil des enfants nés de gpa à
l'étranger
sous réserve bien sûr d'une expertise
judiciaire établissements la filiation
biologique avec le père évidemment ces
sites alors c'est exactement la
transcription de l'arrêt de la cour
européenne des tv nova bus explose il a
parlé de la filiation biologique avec le
perd donc sa voix dans ses décisions ce
que michel gonnot ne disons pas nos ceux
qui nous regardent en erreur ça c'est
l'avis du parquet général oui c'est le
19 juin que les juges de la cour de
cassation en assemblée plénière
décideront mais le parquet général leur
recommande de le faire et comment on le
voit bien avec les justes par exemple
deux camps on le voit il ya une brèche
qui est ouvert de nice certains de
nantes étonnant il ya une brèche qui est
ouverte et
s'alarmer adversaire qui comme vous dis
c'est la marchandisation du corps des
femmes peut dire qu est ce qu on va
faire des enfants qui seront rejetées
parce qu'elles ont une malformation
comme c'est déjà mais ça lui arrive à
une brèche
on aimerait aller jusqu'à l'étape
suivante c'est à dire la légalisation
d'un génial non les deux choses les deux
choses sont séparés reconnaître
l'intérêt de ces enfants qui n'ont rien
demandé et continuer à grandir héberger
sa sonorité aux enfants de mieux à
l'étranger en sciences par cette même
avec mais justement mais c'est pour ça
qu'il faut mener nabeul c'est pour ça
qu'il faut mener une action
internationale d'accord pour que la
gestation pour autrui soit interdit
encore une fois on a un exemple que nous
avons réussi il y a quelques années
c'était notamment chirac et clinton qui
avait pris des positions très fortes
contre l'autre le 20 juin ce que vous
nous dites en fait c'est
qu'effectivement si on donne des papiers
d'identité à ses enfants nés de gpa à
l'étranger c'est une façon donc de
contourner la loi française non ce n'est
pas un contournement l'eau françaises
n'ont aucun nom c'est la reconnaissance
des principes d'une convention
internationale bons qui donnent des
droits aux enfants n'oubliez pas que le
défenseur des droits il est aussi
défenseur des enfants l'adjointe qui est
défenseur des enfants et c'est un des
boulots dans principaux que je fais pas
encore une question quand même là dessus
la députée ump de marseille valérie
boyer estime qu'il faut punir le recours
à une mère porteuse en france ou à
l'étranger et l'imaginent adélie spécial
que répondez vous mais à l'automne je
pense que
d'abord parce que la loi le prévoit déjà
bon donc puisque puisque les
dispositions les dispositions des lois
de bioéthique sont sanctionnés
pénalement à l'heure actuelle plusieurs
dispositions d y compris ceux là pour
donc ce n'est pas utile je dirais et que
d'autre part je ne crois pas que c'est
par la répression qu'on peut régler
cette question on peut régler cette
question en prévoyant une harmonie des
règles pour qu'il n'y ait pas
effectivement vous avez tout à fait
raison de le dire de tourisme dans ce
domaine d'accord alors dans l'actualité
il ya également la question des migrants
je crois que vous vous êtes auto saisie
des violences policières à calais par
exemple récemment on a vu les images
mais on le voit les forces de l'ordre
sont débordées dans notre pays au nord
au sud également l les dirigeants aussi
est-ce que vous plaidez vous pour plus
de générosité dans l'accueil moi je
plaide pour la mise en oeuvre du droit
que ce soit pour le droit d'asile c'est
à dire les personnes qui demandent le
statut de réfugié que ce soit pour les
migrants
lucky ce ne sont pas des réfugiés c'est
à dire qu'ils ne sont pas opprimer qui
viennent pour des raisons familiales
pourrait renommer études pour des
raisons d'études pour des raisons
économiques je je je considère que c'est
la base même de mon travail oui toute
personne humaine est égal et à des
droits égaux et qu'à partir de ce moment
là un pays comme la france et la
république française doit s'honorer de
faire bénéficier tous ceux qui vivent
sur son territoire des mêmes droits
fondamentaux je prends un exemple par
exemple il est totalement scandaleux et
je lutte contre autant que je peux que
on ne donne pas le même accès à la santé
même accès aux soins à les personnes
étrangères et à des personnes qui ont la
nationalité française à partir du moment
où le droit à la santé est un droit
fondamental notamment pour les enfants
ou les droits à l'éducation civique pour
lui angers il mais qui sont d'ailleurs a
contesté par ceux de l'opposition en
charge de la question est de savoir dans
quelles conditions elles sont appliquées
il ya une prestation enfin si un régime
de ce que les seuls qui s'appelle la cmu
il ya un autre régime qui s'appelle la
cmu complémentaire là c'est la musique
n'est plus appliquée parce qu'elle
connaît plus en plus cher oui elle est
de plus en plus appliquée mais elle est
aussi très souvent refusé et je le dis
parce que tout simplement moi je
n'invente pas les problèmes vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que le défenseur des
droits s'occuper de tous seront
clôturées en réalité en réalité je
traduis la demande sociale qui s'exprime
auprès de bakker mais quand elle
s'exprime d'ailleurs comme les s'exprime
d'ailleurs auprès des parlementaires ou
auprès des administrations donc ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que cette
question moi je la considère d'abord non
pas ceux donnant idéologique politique
mais je dis que ces personnes humaines
ont des droits égaux et il faut les en
faire maintenant qu'ils sont en
situation irrégulière mais la situation
comme une aide indique laure et de
présence au territoire sans mentionner
la structure la situation irrégulière
appartement on est présents sur le
territoire c'est le cas par exemple d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont à
calais qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que je
dis moi je dis que ils doivent aller si
effectivement ce sont des personnes
comme par exemple les erythréens vous
les éthiopiens qui sont opprimés se
damner qui sont qui viennent de pays
dans lequel un certain nombre de
personnes pour leur religion ou autres
sont opprimés sont pas sacrées
quelquefois tout simplement il est tout
à fait normal que l'on puisse leur
accorder le droit d'asile et à ce moment
là il faut qu'il le demande c'est une
des voies mais par ailleurs lorsqu'ils
séjournent sur notre territoire ils ont
aussi un certain nombre de droits le
droit qui est un droit fondamental par
exemple à l'hébergement il n'est pas
normal qu'on laisse une personne vivre à
la belle étoile sans avoir un minimum de
confort comme par exemple des toilettes
ou le moyen de celui je crois que ça va
à l'encontre jeu à cause de ce que je
fais il en faut bouder
le défenseur des droits le défenseur des
droits c'est tout sauf un démagogue
c'est clair sur énormément fins
populistes sur énormément de sujets
puisque comme vous voulez mais je paye
un démagogue au sens où sur beaucoup de
sujets ce que je propose que je défends
n'est pas naturellement ce que souhaite
la majorité des gens qui s'expriment par
exemple dans les sondages et alors c'est
comme ça que on peut faire avancer les
choses vous savez il ya bien il ya
beaucoup d'époque ou ceux qui
proposaient des grandes réformes se
trouvait totalement minoritaires 10 ans
15 ans après elles sont passées mois
pour ce qui me concerne je ne m'appuie
pas sur une sorte d' idées politiques
que j'aurais et jeudi le bien et là le
mal là non je dis simplement que il
existe dans les conventions
internationales dans notre constitution
dans un endroit un certain nombre de
droits qui sont à la fois au pluriel et
est au singulier et je n'avais là vous
avez une notion très extensible du droit
quand on vous écoute nommé le droit ce
n'est pas extensif c'est ce qu'ils
règlent nos rapports entre individus
entre groupes nos rapports collectifs
hainaut et nos rapports malgré que ce
soit sur le plan économique que ce soit
adam tous dans tous les niveaux j'ai
d'ailleurs je fais une parenthèse
là-dessus tout simplement pour dire que
moi je suis sidéré et je le suis depuis
toujours que l'on n'enseigne pas le
droit dans les collèges ou dans les
lycées d'ailleurs depuis les tragédies
mois de janvier depuis la grande
manifestation dure onze journées on se
préoccupe d'essayer d'enseigner les
valeurs républicaines et notamment de
donner une formation aux principaux
droits mais ça devrait être fait depuis
pariant le on enseigne un certain nombre
de matières qui peut être dans la vie ne
vous serviront pas peut-être que dans la
vie c'est pas indispensable de savoir
que
415 marignan bon mais en revanche en
revanche savoir ce qu'est un contrat
savoir ce que c'est la responsabilité
civile 2 quand même à ce que vous allez
vous mettre du mandat de oui je suis
absolument je suis absolument rien de ce
qui se bat pour l'enseignement de
l'histoire j'ai fait il ya quatre ans le
musée de l'histoire de l'immigration
pourquoi on raconte une verrée histoire
de la france donc je suis pour
l'histoire mais en même temps mais en
même temps ce que je vais essayer de
faire un truc défenseur des droits c'est
de proposer à l'éducation nationale une
formation au droit je vais utiliser pour
ça les agents les volontaires du service
civique qui vous savez vont être
multipliées et je vais envoyer de jeunes
ambassadeurs dans les collèges et la
corse allez on y va on l'a vu vous
intervenez dans un grand nombre de
domaines vous êtes aussi force de
proposition on le voit vous voulez
veiller au vivre ensemble républicain et
qui est même bousculé en danger on peut
le dire aujourd'hui on va l'évoqué avec
deborah claude de l' agence
france-presse mais d'abord voyons
comment on peut s'adresser à vous c'est
tout bon est à votre service à vos
services avec quel espoir de retour quel
type d'intervention jérôme rabier
alors quel est le problème
discriminés pour cause de handicap
contrôler de façon violente par des
forces de l'ordre prestation injustement
refusée par la caf ou encore refus de
scolarité pour un mineur étranger autant
de situations le défenseur des droits
peut intervenir une institution destinée
à tous est largement saisie l'an dernier
en 2014 défenseur des droits a reçu plus
de 100 une sollicitation dans l'année
parmi lesquels on a dénombré environ 74
mille dossiers de réclamation à
proprement parler des dossiers qui
concernent les relations avec les
services publics représentent 85%
l'attractivité les dossiers en matière
de lutte contre les discriminations
représente environ 10% et puis ce le
résiduel ses 4 % pour les droits de
l'enfant est important en matière de
déontologie de la sécurité créé par la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008 est
institué par une loi de 2011 le
défenseur des droits est encore récent
il regroupe quatre anciennes
institutions le défenseur des enfants le
médiateur de la république la halde qui
gérait les discriminations et la cnds
qui traitait des problèmes avec les
forces de sécurité une fusion pour
éviter les doublons et offrir un guichet
de saisine unique est désormais
facilement accessibles un formulaire de
saisie sur notre site les réclamants
peuvent également écrire directement par
courrier postal au défenseur et enfin
ils peuvent aussi décider de rencontrer
directement la nos délégués
on a une carte interactive sur notre
site internet qui permet de trouver le
délégué qui est le plus proche de son
domicile 500 délégués bénévoles présents
dans les maisons de justice en
préfecture ou dans les points d'accès au
droit ils sont les relais de
l'institution qui peut régler les
dossiers à l'amiable proposé une
transaction pénale réclamaient des
sanctions professionnelles et même
intervenir lors d'un procès quatre ans
après sa création qui avait à l'époque
était largement critiqué le défenseur
des droits est bel et bien installé
comme le recours des personnes dont les
droits ne sont pas respectés
voilà d'abord à claudette avec notre
consoeur de la sp vocation défenseur des
droits
on voit que vous avez un large spectre
d'activités de la ville c'est la vie moi
je crois le défenseur des enfants la
sécurité et notamment dans le dernier
rapport dont je crois qu'on a noté une
augmentation sur ce sujet-là la
déontologie de la sécurité
quel type d'affaires ça recoupe ça
recoupe les
relations violentes par exemple entre un
policier un gendarme gardiens de prison
ou une personne quelqu'un par exemple
qui est mal traitée dans un commissariat
sapeurs autres c'est le je dirais des
situations les plus banales les plus
banales mais ça recouvre aussi des
situations beaucoup plus spectaculaires
comme par exemple
les questions de maintien de l'ordre
je suis amenée par exemple à traiter
les demandes de certaines personnes qui
ont été blessées par exemple dans les
manifestations au moment notre dame des
landes où vous savez que je suis je me
suis saisi d'office aussi à propos de la
mort du jeune rémi de presse sur le
barrage de 200 ans je ne suis pas saisie
je me suis pas saisie pour enquêter là à
moi je fais mon enquête il ya une part
une information judiciaire ça va au
tribunal de mulhouse et je peux disposer
puisque c'est à des pouvoirs du
défenseur des droits du même dossier que
le juge d'instruction donc je suis en
train moi de mon côté d'enquêté est en
fait dans une affaire comme celle là
c'est une affaire comme celle là les
gens du les vidéos et dans més et je
veux le saisir comme exemple dans une
affaire comme celle là moi je ne vais
pas comme va le faire le juge
d'instruction et je dirais la justice
peut être rechercher les responsabilités
individuelles mon travail ça sera plutôt
d'essayer de réfléchir à quelles leçons
tirer d'une affaire dramatique comme
celle ci sur les méthodes de maintien de
l'ordre dans la mesure où aujourd'hui
vous savez très bien que les
manifestations ont changé de nature les
méthodes de ma décision et voilà et de
la même façon je suis venu dans cette
maison ici au sénat il ya quelques jours
et à l'occasion de l'examen d'un texte
sur ce qu'on appelle les armes de force
intermédiaire c'est-à-dire l'état there
et les flash ball j'ai dit qu'il ne
concerne pas mal d'affaires gedik voilà
j'ai dit justement à cause des
nombreuses affaires que j'ai à ce sujet
je demande je suggère que soit interdite
ce qu'on appelle le flash-ball super pro
qui est très imprécis et qui fait des
blessures parce qu'on peut pas viser par
exemple ces voilà le genre de cavaliers
en matière de déontologie de la sécurité
effectivement nous avons beaucoup plus
d'affaires je crois que ça tient à une
question qui est une question qui a été
posée au moment des tragédies du mois de
janvier c'est la difficulté des
relations entre la police et la
population et les jeunes mamans police
et les jeunes et c'est pour ça que
dominique baudis avant moi et moi
maintenant nous nous intéressons à la
question des contrôles d'identité et
c'est vrai que sa ville est d'essayer de
faire en sorte que les contrôles
d'identité choix mieux donc ça fait
penser à un dramatique affaire que dans
l'actualité en ce moment la relaxe dix
ans après devant un tribunal
correctionnelle de deux policiers et
après la mort de deux jeunes gounod
voilà il ya eu un certain nombre de
réactions
une jeune député du front national
parler de racailles qui avait mis le feu
aux banlieues est-ce que ça est ce que
ce genre de réactions se sont
susceptibles d'alimenter un petit peu
aussi justement les difficultés entre
les forces de police qui met de l'eau de
l'huile sur le feu naturellement
lamentable moi je dirais dans cette
affaire que qui a créé beaucoup
d'émotion effectivement hier mais que la
justice est passée et elle est passée de
mon point de vue je générant du bourget
était il ya vingt ans j'ai été il ya 20
ans ministre la justice donc je sais un
peu de quoi je parle je crois que la
justice a fonctionné de manière normale
donc toutes ces procédures et qui le
souhaitent quels besoins en bois m'est
arrivé de montrer les enquêtes les
hommes oui mais il y avait eu plusieurs
décisions auparavant n'oublions pas que
c'est la décision ultime était que et
que eux on peut dire si vous voulez que
quels que soient les sentiments qu'on
peut très bien comprendre des uns ou des
autres la douleur des uns des autres
quels que soient les motions que crée ce
genre de situation il faut admettre que
la justice est passée et qu'elle a été
rendue en moi et vous savez très bien
que le défenseur des droits d'ailleurs
un moyen de mettre et vos reer les
autorités la chose du jury âgées c'est
quand même assez fortement au tweet
effectivement de marion maréchal le pen
qui s'était réjouie de la décision de
justice en disant c'est bien la preuve
que c'est la racaille qui avait mis le
feu aux banlieues il même s'il ajoute
non plus hein je réagis d'une peur en
disant que dire ça c'est lamentable
parce que ça ne peut qu'aggraver les
problèmes pour l'avenir et deuxièmement
je réagis parce que ce n'est pas du tout
ce qu'a dit le jugement le jugement n'a
pas du tout du tout décrit les deux
garçons ont ils sont morts justement
comme des délinquants mais quand
l'avocat à la rocade de la famille de
zied et bouna monsieur mignard dit qu'il
y à un apartheid judiciaire dans notre
pays il dit vrai là non il a tort je
pense franchement que notre justice
fonctionne de manière égale vous savez
c'est toujours la question quand j'étais
en charge 1995 96 j'ai fait je me
souviens très bien des journées de la
justice deux années de suite après l'ont
été primé pour informer nos concitoyens
sur ce qu'était justement les enjeux de
la justice et j'avais fait un grand
sondage on s'apercevait que la justice
était l'un des services publics qui
avait le moins de d'opinions favorables
le mieux c'était les télécoms parce
qu'actuellement le téléphone tout ça ça
marche très bien france et que et que et
que
mais pour une raison d'abord simple
c'est que n'oublions jamais qu'en
matière de justice il ya toujours un
gagnant et un perdant il ya toujours une
accusation qui obtient satisfaction une
défense qui gagnent ou qu'ils perdent
eux la justice est par définition un
moyen qui a été inventé il ya plus de
2000 ans ou trois mille ans en grèce et
qui a été qui a pour but de faire en
sorte que on remplace un règlement
organisées dans des conflits remplace
pour les conflits la violence
personnelle dans pour dent en quelque
sorte par un règlement organisé et il
faut l'admettre le consensus sur la
justice est un des éléments forts du
contrat social fallu d'autres ce cadre
elle n'a pas toujours consensus autre
autre sujet les discriminations c'est
effectivement parfois on les retrouve
aussi au tribunal c'est un de vos thèmes
également je crois vous avez milité pour
un recours collectif sa discrimination
et crois que cet après midi on a 7
chemin tu nous avais 7 sec ce matin il
ya eu la remise au ministre du travail
monsieur françois rebsamen qui avait
réuni depuis six mois un groupe de
travail
sur ces questions de discrimination dans
l'emploi il y a eu la remise d'un
rapport d'un groupe de travail auquel
d'ailleurs le défenseur des droits à
participer et ce groupe à deux
conclusions les plus notoires c'est
d'une part il n'a pas retenu
l'obligation du cv anonyme et ça
correspond à notre opinion nous avons un
métier cousin que vous avez aimé le
défenseur des droits a fait des études
en 2011 de migration pour dire que ce
n'est pas la solution il faut employer
plusieurs méthodes et par exemple ce qui
vient d'être proposé le recrutement par
simulation c'est à dire que on fait
jouer à quelqu'un que l'on veut recruter
la situation de l'emploi qui
il demande donc il y a plus m'étonner en
tout cas c'est une bonne décision de ne
pas obliger le cv données et au suriname
et d'autre part et d'autre part l'odeur
décision importante c'est la possibilité
d'en vau collective que ça ne te vire a
annoncé que ce serait dans la loi
qu'elle va présenter justice 21 qui
normalement on va passer au conseil des
ministres à la fin de ce mois ci et je
pense au parlement à l'automne nous y
sommes favorables parce que le recours
collectif
c'est une manière non pas seulement de
réprimer le languedocien à venir les dix
la pression sur les vraies celles vie
suaad vous savez la plupart des
employeurs ne sont pas des
discriminateur né fait pas d aucuns
entre eux c'est en réalité
pour les faits les jeunes qui viennent
des banlieues en plus de mal à ses
fautes mais bien sûr mais vous savez nos
études sont formelles en matière de
discrimination la première cause c'est
l'origine la seconde c'est le handicap
la troisième c'est laisser l'état de
santé la quatrième c'est le sexe si vous
êtes une femme ou un homme et justement
c'est pour ça que par ailleurs je me
bats alors qu'on tient monsieur rebsamen
en l'occurrence pour que il met dans son
texte sur le dialogue social
le rapport sur la situation comparée
c'est à dire ce qui permet dans chaque
entreprise de plus de 300 personnes mais
savent chaque année obtenu satisfaction
oui a priori les revenus ses revenus
dans la loire dont il y aura diagnostic
de l'inégalité hommes-femmes dans les
objets et j'attends que ce soir ce soit
déposé l'amendement pour voir si c'est
exactement la bonne situation pour
parler de discrimination aura lieu à
l'école également ce sont c'est un thème
important comment faire pour lutter
contre les discriminations à l'école
contre le on peut penser au détournement
de la carte scolaire est ce que ce sont
également des petits nous passions
beaucoup travaillé à tous les travaux
les études travaux pour lutter contre
les stéréotypes
à la barre et 7,6 à tour est-ce que vous
estimez que les enfants qui ils sont
issus de milieux défavorisés ont leurs
droits bafoués à l'école aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il ya une situation
très grave dont on parle trop peu c de
la pauvreté je pense que il y a eu des
rapports récemment d'ailleurs qui ont en
effet et au titre du droit des enfants
quand on parle par exemple la justice
des mineurs je crois qu'on peut pas
parler de justice des mineurs comme ça
en l'air isolé il faut savoir à quoi ça
s'applique et il y à des familles et des
enfants étaient réticents dans un hôtel
l'état de pauvreté que on peut se poser
la question de quel droit élémentaire si
j'ose dire peuvent-ils avoir à partir du
moment où par exemple
il ya des enfants qui ne mangent qu'une
fois à la cantine c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que l'accès égal de tous à la
cantine et quelque chose d'absolument
pour le mental et je me suis battu pour
ça vous même je crois que vous expliquez
que ce sont plutôt des classes moyennes
qui saisissent les institutions
auxquelles ce président en 2000 et les
plus démunis savent ce que c'est une
action que le but de souder fraîcheur le
piège ses défenseurs je me suis donné
une priorité c'est faire en sorte que
les personnes notamment les personnes
les plus démunies à la fois
économiquement culturellement ou qui
sont géographiquement éloignés
soit davantage concernés c'est-à-dire
qu'elles puissent connaître leurs droits
qu'elles puissent saisir défenseur des
droits ou toute autre formule d'ailleurs
peu importe je n'ai pas de monopole mais
qu' il n'y ait pas effectivement en
france deux ou trois vitesses c'est à
dire des personnes qui n'ont aucun
problème des personnes qui ont des
problèmes mais qui savent comment les
régler et puis d'autres personnes qui
ont de graves problèmes et qu'ils sont
démunis est complètement dévoué et ça
c'est mon travail ça s'appelle la
promotion de l'égalité bakugan la
question de bord
encore une est ce que les statistiques
ethniques pourraient être un moyen
également de lutter contre les
discriminations qu'elle est on sait que
le débat est assez hausse engagée en
faussant les statistiques ethniques
c'est a rejeté le mot statistiques
ethniques et la notion mais en revanche
et donc je n'y suis pas favorable quand
on parle de statistiques mais en
revanche en vain qu'on fasse des
dénombrements qu'on fasse des études
comme des études d'ailleurs qui existent
déjà par exemple trajectoires et
origines qui sont des études qui t'ont
fait par l'institut yad nationale dont
les stats et qui sont et qui consiste
par exemple à rechercher
le lieu de naissance ou la nationalité
des parents à partir de ce moment là on
peut faire un travail et moi je suis
partisan de ce point de vue d'assouplir
les règles statistiques mais je suis
hostile à ce qu'on appelle improprement
les statistiques ethniques mais le mot
le mot fait balle mais il est clair que
il serait complètement contraire aux
principes de la république d'assigner
chacun à sa condition d'origine et en
particulier à sa couleur d'accord merci
des bras alors perdre interne au arrive
maintenant on va parler de vous jacques
toubon on le voit votre engagement et
puis votre choix par le président de la
république après une longue carrière
politique derrière un seul homme paul
bouffard
il fait ses débuts en politique il ya
presque 50 ans jacques toubon un
chiraquien pur jus un pilier du clan
chirac en 1983 il devient maire du xiiie
arrondissement de paris à cette époque
un autre élu parisien jean-françois
legaret le côtoient il se rappelle je
crois que chirac avait dit un jour je me
demande si en campagne tout bon est pas
meilleur que moi c'est un animal
politique un animal politique avec tout
ce que ça comporte je dirais de
d'instinctif de voilà c'est un homme qui
ce qui fait de la politique
au feeling
avec avec ses amis c'est un homme qui
qui qui chassent en bande dans le
gouvernement balladur en 1993 jacques
toubon devient ministre de la culture on
le surnomme monsieur all good avec sa
loi en faveur de la francophonie en 1995
il devient garde des sceaux et le
ministre rpr fait parler de lui dans la
sphère de l'hélicoptère pour éviter la
mise en examen de l'épousé du maire de
paris xavière tiberi il déploie des
moyens hors norme jacques toubon envoie
un hélicoptère dans l'himalaya pour
faire signer un document aux magistrats
en charge de la faire en juin dernier la
gauche grincent des dents quand françois
hollande propose le nom de jacques
toubon au poste de défenseur des droits
après l'hélicoptère des prises de
positions vieille de 30 ans refont
surface une pétition contre cette
nomination voit le jour julien bayou
porte parole d'europe écologie les verts
en est l'instigateur il nous faut un
superman contre les discriminations une
superwoman pourrait cependant pas
innover un peu et faire appel à la
société civile un magistrat une
magistrate en a voulu une avocate un
défenseur une militante ong il ya un
vrai problème de discrimination en
france et on a l'impression qu'on fait
des petites mesures alors que c'est un
big bang qu'il faudrait faire pas de big
bang aujourd'hui dix mois après sa prise
de fonctions jacques toubon at il trouvé
sa place au poste de défenseur des
droits voilà perrine tarneaud nous a
rejoint françois perin vos questions au
défenseur des droits qui cherchent tous
à trouver sur place on va voir en tout
cas julien bayou dit pas de big bang a
pas de big bang pour l'instant je
précise d'ailleurs le big bang je traite
en tout cas aujourd'hui par exemple 20 %
de dossiers de lutte contre les
discriminations de plus que nous
n'avions il ya quatre ans donc on peut
pas dire que la lutte contre les
discriminations reculer et par exemple
citer par exemple sur eux et par exemple
sur eux ce qui vient d'être
décidez vous proposé par le par le
gouvernement on voit bien que nous avons
la possibilité avec le recours collectif
de faire une sorte de show vers une
promotion de l'égalité encore plus
efficace c'est vrai qu'il y avait
quelques critiques au moment de la
nomination
du jeu politique est ce que vous estimez
aujourd'hui vous avez réussi à faire
taire ses critiques est vous êtes
installés dans ce cas moi je ne peut
porter que les témoignages que je reçois
tout le monde demande à ce que
j'intervienne tous les parlementaires de
tous bords de toutes les commissions me
demande d avis sur les textes ou sur tel
ou tel sujet moi même mes adjoints mais
220 collaborateurs
nous sommes sans arrêt sollicités pour
participer à des tables aurons nous
sommes en train d'engager montre aussi
que le défenseur des droits est
durablement installé dans la wii mais ça
nous avait beaucoup de critiques de sa
cotation ça montre simplement que la
mission que nous remplissons correspond
à un besoin et que grâce à dominique
baudis qui a présidé l'institution
pendant trente trois mois avant de
disparaître malheureusement et puis moi
depuis maintenant neuf mois nous avons
une certaine légitimité c'est
incontestable et je le vois bien
j'entretiens des relations très étroites
avec les parlementaires avec les deux
commissions des lois et je viens de
déjeuner à un instant avec la commission
des lois du sénat par exemple eh bien il
est clair que ce qui est
sentie ressentie par les parlementaires
c'est que nous faisons un travail qui
finalement sert en quelque sorte la
république comme il essaye de le faire
eux mêmes chacun avec leur couleur
politique moi j'ai pas de couleur
politique quand même évident perdu votre
couleur politique ah oui totalement un
parti politique
non ce n'est pas un poster ou alors une
expérience attendait ou alors il faut ou
alors il faut donner un sens au mot
politique qui est effectivement de gérer
la cité ça en ce sens c'est un poste
politique parce que c'est clair que
répondent aux demandes sociales faire en
sorte qu'une personne qui est au pied de
son escalier dans un hlm éloignées qui
va voir notre délégué qui a un vrai
problème ça peut être un problème de
deux ou trois mille euros mais deux ou
trois mille euros pour coût de gens
c'est sommes absolument énorme bon donc
qui va et qui un mois ou deux mois après
va se retrouver à récupérer ses deux ou
trois mille euros c'est clair que là on
a fait quelque chose qui a fait avancer
ce qui par ailleurs ont employé le moins
tentations tout à l'heure les valeurs de
la république les valeurs républicaines
la devise de la république mais ils font
l'incarner et moi le défenseur des
droits à mon niveau j'essaye de lui
donner une réalité en tout cas on sent
qu'il ya un certain plaisir de votre
parent revenir sur le devant de la scène
sur le devant de la scène quand on me
demande moi je n'ai pas besoin même
temps ni à mon avis après tout ce que
j'ai fait j'ai pas besoin mettre un
moment je ne postule à rien je ne suis
pas candidat
je suis heureux dans ce que je fais et
je suis surtout heureux lorsque je vois
des croupes des individus qui pensent
que le défenseur des droits peut
apporter une solution à leur problème
mais il ya beaucoup de cas où je n'y
peux rien notamment par exemple lorsque
la justice a tranché je ne peux pas
revenir sur une décision judiciaire mais
en revanche il y à beaucoup de
situations dans lesquelles je peux
apporter en droit ou en équité une seule
chose est lé tout à l'heure dans le
reportage on citer par exemple les
retraites mais plus récemment regarder
le rapport que j'ai fait sur les
mutuelles étudiantes il n'a pas pour but
de taille soit sur les mutuelles et il a
pour but de dire que c'est quand même
scandaleux que les droits à la santé des
étudiants ne soient pas correctement
avec les renvoyant qui tarde à venir au
lycée pour les étudiants vous avez parlé
de l'incarnation des valeurs
républicaines et vous pensez que c'est
pas forcément votre rôle a avoué y en a
d'autres qui sont aussi les mêmes dans
son chef de l'état dès les essais des
salles de françois hollande on sent ce
bourbier politique politique parce que
je suis une incision la république je
rappelle que le défenseur des droits a
été créée par la constitution par la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008 bon
nous sommes une loi organique 2011 et
nous sommes nés sait déjà que nous ne
sommes pas une autorité administrative
indépendante je dirais technique ou
économique
nous avons effectivement un rôle qui est
social et politique mais nous le faisons
à travers le droit et sur les fractures
aussi parfois de la république allant
jusque michel évoqué françois hollande
c'est vrai qu' on est dans une période
un peu de commémoration il va y avoir le
discours de l'entrée au panthéon le 27
mai 26 chasseurs de pierre cholette
geneviève de gaulle germaine tillion et
et josé je les lisais dix préparent ce
qui devrait être enfin c'est ce qu'ils
disent le discours du quinquennat ce que
j'ai l'impression que françois hollande
qui a correctement son rôle de garant de
gardiens des valeurs de la consommation
possible défenseur des droits pas
répondre à cette question
je suis ni le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste sinon président l'ump
je peux répondre en disant qu' il a
raison il assiste profondément raison
d'avoir choisi ces quatre personnes qui
sont très représentatives d'un certain
nombre effectivement de valeur mais pas
seulement deux valeurs elles ont
justement incarner les valeurs je dirai
au péril de leur peau 1 elles ont
incarné cesser ses valeurs et je trouve
qu'il est tout à fait bon que
effectivement elle soit panthéon 10 et
elles soient mises en lumière aux yeux
de toute la nation et j'espère
effectivement qu'à cette occasion le
président république pourra se dire et
tout simplement réunir une grande partie
des personnes qui vivent chez nous
pauvres riches
éloigné
nantis
autour de ces de ces principes qui sont
encore une fois ce que moi j'ai en
charge à mon niveau c'est à dire les
droits et les libertés fondamentales
c'est ça que dit la constitution
défendre les droits et les libertés
pendant que vous l'avez demandé pourquoi
il vous a choisi
je crois qu'il m'a choisie parce que mon
profil
ce que j'aimerais c'est depuis 40 ans
correspondait assez à ce qu'ils
attendent et je n'ai pas eu l'occasion
de lui dire pourquoi c'est moi je les
remercier le dr mercier non et je pense
que les jeux
paraît important c'est que et ça ça m'a
été très bien très explicitement dit le
président un public souhaitait que ce
soit quelqu'un qui ne soit pas de son
camp politique qui soit 2 de l'autre
camp politique c'est clair c'était son
choix
naturellement françois hollande
dans mon pendant les 35 ou 40 années où
j'ai fait de la politique du côté où je
laissais du côté de la droite du côté
des gaullistes
vous pouvez les appeler comme vous
voulez c'est clair que j'ai souvent été
dans ma propre famille quelqu'un qui a
manifesté beaucoup d'ouverture par
exemple vous parliez des migrants tout à
l'heure c'est clair que quand dans ma
famille quelqu'un a dit il faut remettre
en cause le droit du sol et il ya
quelqu'un qui un jour dans une réunion
c'était il ya quelques années que c'est
des réseaux du tout cvc s'est dressée et
a dit mais ça c'est totalement contraire
à va de familles non seulement à notre
intérêt mais aux principes de la
république il ya des politiques
aujourd'hui un certain discours
politique qui ne facilite pas le vivre
enfin mais qui servent toujours sur les
crispations l'associé mais vous savez ce
que je peux faire moi c'est d'y répondre
justement nous pas en faisant des
proclamations de communiquer mais
concrètement dans des postures mais en
reconnaissant mary's en pas telle ou
telle personne dont le droit à la santé
est niée et bien en lui reconnaissant
d'une certaine façon je dis à ce moment
là que cette personne appartient à notre
république et n'en est pas exclu quel
regard vous avez porté sur la polémique
autour d'emmanuel todd et de son livre
après les manifestations du onze anglais
je vais vous dire il avait demandé mais
je n'ai pas lu je n'ai pas lu le livre
ggd libre et j'ai dit oui j'ai lu des
livres comme celui que ce soit guy lit
par exemple sur la façon dont la france
bnf eric je pense depuis très longtemps
moi je me suis occupé je le rappelais de
leurs deux questions d'immigration et
d'intégration depuis déjà 25 ans ne
serait ce que par mon expérience
personnelle j'ai été dix huit ans maire
du xiiie arrondissement c'est qu'une
ville monde le 13ème arrondissement donc
je jouerai mieux avoir cette expérience
finalement de parler de penser
différemment par cette expérience dans
cette expérience je j'ai toujours été
acquis donc à ses idées l'immigration et
l'intégration et g je souffre beaucoup
quand on refuse de reconnaître que notre
pays notre identité puisqu'on parle de
notre identité et multiples que nous
sommes une nation qui n'a pas été
inventé comme ça en sortant du massif
air signant du massif central un jour
mais nous sommes une nation construite
nous sommes un pays qui a été con et qui
a été construit en particulier par
l'état que ce soit sur la royauté ou que
ce soit depuis après la révolution parle
par la république et donc et donc de ce
point de vue les débats qui ont lieu
actuellement sont des débats tout à fait
essentiel je n'ai pas lu le livre
d'emmanuel todd je peux simplement dire
pour avoir été présent dans la
manifestation où j'avais été invité par
le président d'un public comme un
certain nombre de personnalités je peux
simplement dire que j ai vu des
personnes très diverses voilà c'est
simple à mettre en place juste pour
finir très rapidement ce qui nous reste
une minute sur la laïcité dont on parle
beaucoup aussi actuellement est-ce qu'il
faut être plus ou moins intransigeant
avec certains principes de laïcité ça ne
veut rien dire l'intransigeant la
laïcité c'est de prendre la liberté si
c'est la reconnaissance que la
république fait de la liberté de
conscience de la liberté de penser de la
liberté de culte à partir du moment où
vous posez ça il est clair que l'idée
qu'ils auraient une laïcité dure et inna
is it est molle en quelque sorte est une
idée fausse il faut simplement dire que
par exemple le service public doit être
neutre mais que dans le privé on n'a pas
appliquer les mêmes règles que dans le
service public par exemple et puis
d'autre part il faut chercher à faire ce
que moi je fais très souvent parce que
le défenseur droit c'est à dire de créer
des situations où on peut avoir de la
médiation et non pas de lamentations
mais surtout ne faisons pas de la
laïcité un principe de combat a is it et
c'est ce qui nous permet d'être ensemble
et pas de nous diviser merci jacques
aumont merci perrine bonsoir à tous et à
très vite à la semaine prochaine